- [Instructor] So what we have here
are two different polynomials, P1 and P2.
And they have been
expressed in factored form
and you can also see their graphs.
This is the graph of Y is
equal to P1 of x in blue,
and the graph of Y is
equal to P2 x in white.
What we're going to do in this video
is continue our study of zeros,
but we're gonna look at a special case
when something interesting
happens with the zeros.
So let's just first look at P1's zeros.
So I'll set up a little table
here, because it'll be useful.
So the first column, let's
just make it the zeros,
the x values at which our
polynomial is equal to zero
and that's pretty easy to
figure out from factored form.
When x is equal to one,
the whole thing's going
to be equal to zero
because zero times anything is zero.
When x is equal to two,
by the same argument,
and when x is equal to three.
And we can see it here on the graph,
when x equals one,
the graph of y is equal to
P1 intersects the x axis.
It does it again at the
next zero, x equals two.
And at the next zero, x equals three.
We can also see the property
that between consecutive
zeros our function,
our polynomial maintains the same sign.
So between these first two,
or actually before this
first zero it's negative,
then between these
first two it's positive,
then the next two it's negative,
and then after that it is positive.
Now what about P2?
Well P2 is interesting,
'cause if you were to multiply this out,
it would have the same degree as P1.
In either case, you would
have an x to the third term,
you would have a third degree polynomial.
But how many zeros,
how many distinct unique
zeros does P2 have?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well let's just list them out.
So our zeros,
well once again if x equals one,
this whole expression's
going to be equal to zero,
so we have zero at x equals one,
and we can see that our
white graph also intersects
the x axis at x equals one.
And then if x is equal to three,
this whole thing's going
to be equal to zero,
and we can see that it intersects
the x axis at x equals three.
And then notice, this next part
of the expression would say,
"Oh, whoa we have a
zero at x equals three,"
but we already said that, so
we actually have two zeros
for a third degree polynomial,
so something very
interesting is happening.
In some ways you could say that hey,
it's trying to reinforce
that we have a zero at x minus three.
And this notion of having multiple parts
of our factored form that would
all point to the same zero,
that is the idea of multiplicity.
So let me write this word down.
So multiplicity.
Multiplicity,
I'll write it out there.
And I will write it
over here, multiplicity.
And so for each of these zeros,
we have a multiplicity of one.
There are only, they only deduced one time
when you look at it in factored form,
only one of the factors
points to each of those zeros.
So they all have a multiplicity of one.
For P2, the first zero
has a multiple of one,
only one of the expressions
points to a zero of one,
or would become zero if
x would be equal to one.
But notice, out of our factors,
when we have it in factored form,
out of our factored expressions,
or our expression factors I should say,
two of them become zero
when x is equal to three.
This one and this one
are going to become zero,
and so here we have a multiplicity of two.
And I encourage you to
pause this video again
and look at the behavior of graphs,
and see if you can see a difference
between the behavior of the graph
when we have a multiplicity of one
versus when we have a multiplicity of two.
All right, now let's
look through it together.
We could look at P1 where all of the zeros
have a multiplicity of one,
and you can see every time we have a zero
we are crossing the x axis.
Not only are we intersecting
it, but we are crossing it.
We are crossing the x axis
there, we are crossing it again,
and we're crossing it again,
so at all of these we have a
sign change around that zero.
But what happens here?
Well on the first zero that
has a multiplicity of one,
that only makes one of
the factors equal zero,
we have a sign change,
just like we saw with P1.
But what happens at x equals three
where we have a multiplicity of two?
Well there, we intersect the x axis still,
P of three is zero, but notice
we don't have a sign change.
We were positive before,
and we are positive after.
We touch the x axis right
there, but then we go back up.
And the general idea, and I
encourage you to test this out,
and think about why this is true,
is that if you have an odd multiplicity,
now let me write this down.
If the multiplicity is odd,
so if it's one, three, five,
seven et cetera, then you're
going to have a sign change.
Sign change.
While if it is even, as the
case of two, or four, or six,
you're going to have no sign change.
No sign,
no sign change.
One way to think about it,
in an example where you
have a multiplicity of two,
so let's just use this zero
here, where x is equal to three,
when x is less than three,
both of these are going to be negative,
and a negative times and
negative is a positive.
And when x is greater than three,
both of 'em are going to be positive,
and so in either case you have a positive.
So notice, you saw no sign change.
Another thing to appreciate
is thinking about the number
of zeros relative to the
degree of the polynomial.
And what you see is is
that the number of zeros,
number of zeros is
at most equal to the
degree of the polynomial,
so it is going to be less than or equal to
the degree of the polynomial.
And why is that the case?
Well you might not, all
your zeros might have
a multiplicity of one,
in which case the number
of zeros is equal, is going to be equal
to the degree of the polynomial.
But if you have a zero
that has a higher than one multiplicity,
well then you're going to
have fewer distinct zeros.
Another way to think about it is,
if you were to add all the multiplicities,
then that is going to be equal
to the degree of your polynomial.